bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur un
rt france que prévoit ce projet de
traité international cet inédit
alors ce n'est pas tout d'abord je
m'excuse je n'ai pas lu cette tribune
capa qui a été publiée dans le monde
hier
d'après ce que j'ai compris des extraits
de presse que j'ai pu lire ce n'est pas
tout à fait inédit parce que le droit
international en matière sanitaire a
déjà une assez longue histoire puisque
en 1851 paris il ya eu une première
conférence sanitaire international qui
était consacrée aux vocaux les reins en
1907 il ya eu la création toujours à
paris d'un office international de
d'hygiène publique
et puis on dans le cas de la société des
nations
en 1921 donc la société des nations qui
lançait des nations unies on a créé un
comité permanent pour s'occuper de la
santé
alors c'est vrai qu'ils lui ce règlement
sanitaire international 2005 en fait il
est pas tout à fait nouveau puisque son
origine il ya une première version en
1951 qui a été le considérablement à
plusieurs reprises le réviser donc on
n'est pas du tout en terre inconnue mais
en même temps cette tribune montre le
sérieux de responsables politiques pour
le prendre en quelque sorte le taureau
par les cornes et c'est vraiment une
très bonne nouvelle mais c'est surtout
une entreprise de communication alors si
je vous comprends bien puisque ce projet
de traité international devrait reposer
sur ce règlement sanitaire international
que vous évoquiez à l'instant il existe
donc déjà un certain nombre d'outils
juridiques au plan international pour se
coordonner
alors ce sont des outils juridiques mais
qui sont pas du tout contraignant le
règlement international sanitaires
internationales
il est bien sûr applicable par les états
mais il n'y a pas de mécanisme de
sanction est toute la question qui va se
poser si l'on se lance dans le cadre de
l' oms vers la rédaction d'une
convention international le visant les
pandémies
à venir est bien là ce moment là il
faudra certainement si on veut être
sérieux de prévoir un mécanisme au moins
de surveillance ou de contrôle qui
cherchent à vérifier le respect par les
états de leurs engagements
internationaux
c'est un très grand souci évidemment
c'est à dire qu'un traité comme celui
qui est annoncé pour être utile doit
opposer des règles communes
qu'est ce que cela impliquerait surtout
en matière sanitaire
alors il d'après ce que j'ai compris de
la tribune il s'agirait en matière de
vaccins de mécanismes de prévention des
maladies et cetera d'aller bien au delà
de ce qui existe actuellement pour un
certain nombre de pandémie qui sont bien
identifiés pour en quelque sorte
renforcer cette coopération
internationale entre les états et par
conséquent on a remarqué que plusieurs
grands états n'ont pas fini et
responsables n'ont pas signé cette
tribune
ce qui ne veut pas dire que tôt ou tard
ils ne vont pas essayer de monter dans
le train en marche et pour essayer donc
de ne pas notamment vis-à-vis de leurs
opinions publiques ne pas paraître à la
traîne ou de mauvais joueurs au mauvais
perdant donc ce qui est vraiment capital
à mon avis en tout cas si on se place
ce qui serait tout à fait naturel dans
le cadre de l' oms pour élaborer cette
convention internationale il faudra bien
définir ce que l'on veut atteindre et
surtout par quels mécanismes on va
s'assurer du contrôle du respect des
engagements de chaque état qu aurait
changé au début de la botte de la
pandémie que changerait aujourd'hui tech
très concrètement un tel traité s'il
existait on peut imaginer qu'il aurait
évité cette impression désastreuse et
contreproductive de sauve qui peut c'est
à dire où chacun a voulu dans son coin
protégé à court terme ses intérêts
quitte à nuire à d'autres états bien
évidemment mais aussi à l'ensemble du
bien-être de l'humanité si on ne peut
pas être trop confiant fatick
donc c'est quelque chose qui c'est un
instrument international s'il voit le
jour
qui pourrait être extrêmement utile et
éviter justement les très nombreuses
erreurs ou cacophonie auquel on a
assisté ces dernières années ont passé
depuis plus d'un an
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
de vincent berger avocat spécialiste en
droit international